Continental Tire coaches corner brought
to you by Continental Tire you'll see
Continental Tire and supporting venues
across the United States including
college basketball Continentals premium
products available at leading
independent tire dealers car dealers
mass retail companies across North
America for more information visit
Continental Tire Calm Continental Tire
for what you do new head coach at Texas
formerly of Houston he's Tom Herman back
on the program coach congratulations
where are you this morning I'm at my
office right now and in Austin getting
ready to hit the road recruiting what's
in the office right now not a whole lot
that there's a few pictures a few
trophies in the office but there's not a
whole lot me and my wife we got our jobs
ahead of us to decorate it when did you
agree to the Texas job oh boy like 4:00
in the morning on Saturday morning
so it's Saturday morning ok Sunday
morning or Saturday morning Saturday it
was the the it was Saturday morning
because we had played that day that's
Friday why 4:00 in the morning ok well
if you know the timeline is that
important we can you know I got a phone
call when we landed from the Memphis
game and said that some people from
Texas wanted to meet with me and so the
meeting didn't start till about 10:30 at
night and went that long to figure
something out I know we talked during
the season twice about this and it's a
it's a dangerous game we play it's a
tight rope you guys have to walk and
there's nothing wrong with getting
another job a better job or bigger job
and I certainly understand that but the
comments after the Memphis game where
you're telling a reporter that don't
believe any of this were you being
sincere at the
yeah that all of the reports that were
that were out that were floating around
at the time it was before the Memphis
game but not after and every single
report that was floating out at that
time was inaccurate so I I was not lying
I felt very comfortable saying that what
about the LSU opportunity did they reach
out to you yeah I you know and not to
skirt the question I just I don't know
that how we got here is relevant what's
really relevant is that we're here now
dan and and excited about moving forward
excited about the kids in the locker
room excited about getting on the road
recruiting so you know there's a lot of
things that that happen that that have
been reported and and that did or didn't
happen but I you know at the end of the
day I don't know how any of that is is
relevant you know I'm great with the
team at Houston and I never once lied to
them I never told them anything that was
that was false and so those are the only
people that that I need to make my peace
with and I've done that I've gotten
numerous phone calls and texts all
positive from my former players at the
University of Houston and from boosters
and administration there and so I've
moved on and I think you know I think
it's smart for everybody else to - well
I understand I'm just fascinated with
the process here because it puts you in
a difficult position that's all and I
don't know if there's a way to make the
process better other than saying having
complete honesty and saying look I'm
exploring other jobs while I'm coaching
here or you know you're not that you're
not the first coach and you're not the
last coach but is position yeah it is
and they all they all twist and turn in
different ways - but you know I I think
again and I guess for advice for anybody
you're right I'm not the last coach that
this will happen to but you know as long
as you're honest with your players and
your the team I think I think you're
good and you know you don't need to tell
the media everything you don't need to
tell you know Joe
fan everything as long as you're honest
with your teammates or with your team
and your coaches I think you can put
your head down on the pillow at night
and rest easy did you have to sell
yourself to Texas or the other way
around
oh I think there was a little bit of
both
to be honest with you my biggest thing I
wanted to know their vision for Texas
football and moving forward I wanted to
know president fenves is and and Mike
Perrin the athletic director I wanted to
know if their vision for Texas football
aligned with mine and through those
talks I came away very convinced that
that that will be the case that we will
be aligned together in what we need in
terms of resources and support to bring
texas football back to its rightful
place among the the college football
elite going back to what I asked you a
couple of weeks ago if Houston makes the
big 12 my gut feeling was you'd stay now
I don't know if that's you know true or
not but was that a curveball in the
whole process here I'm not sure you know
I it's again it's so hypothetical I
don't know that I ever gave it that was
close though I mean there was
discussions of you guys oh yeah yeah
yeah but but it didn't I never thought
about you know how this is going to
affect whether I stay at Houston or not
and that that never really crossed my
mind how do you sell Texas after what's
happened the last three years
well you sell it as you know we're the
flagship university for the greatest
football playing state in our country
and we've won multiple national
championships we played for multiple
national championships we've won
conference championships and we've got
some some young talent on the team that
needs some direction and you know but to
sell it to recruits I mean it's easy we
got the you know some of the best
facilities in the country we've got some
of the best fans we we've got a great
education here at the University of
Texas to sell them and a great city in
Austin so
the recruiting will not be hard at the
University of Texas we will you know
continue we've got so much experience
recruiting the state of Texas and such
good relationships with the high school
coaches here that selling this place
will not be difficult now we need to we
need to stay competitive with you know
with the elite teams in the country the
Alabama is the Ohio State's the
Clemson's of the world in terms of our
facilities and and our resources and
support staff and recruiting staff and
all that but at the end of the day we're
still the University of Texas and with
this plan and this vision and and you
know what we're going to be able to do
we're gonna win a bunch of championships
while we're here you took the job at
4:00 in the morning did you have to wake
your wife or was she already awake no
she she was on the phone as we were
talking about it and so you know I'm not
DP I don't know about you man but I'm
not gonna make any decisions like that
without wit up without calling her and
making sure she's good with it so she
was on the phone I did I woke her up
with the phone call but she was on the
phone you know pretty much the last 45
minutes to an hour
what are you doing the meeting what are
you doing with your Houston gear I I
don't know you know anytime I would you
change jobs you know this is not the
first time I've changed jobs so usually
try to give it to you know the as good a
fans you know that you've become close
to or some have a guard say let's have a
tag sale have your money phonetic sale
yeah you know I when I was a GA and I
left Texas back in 2000 actually did
because I needed the money but you know
I just think given it to people that
deserve it and even giving it to kids
and and organizations that can better
use it as better than trying to trying
to put a price tag on it and selling it
how much did you make as a grad
assistant I made four hundred dollars a
month and trying to live in Austin Texas
my wife was working back in Los Angeles
she was my fiancee at the time and she
she would you know send me money to help
pay rent
so yeah for 400 bucks a month DP you've
made $400 since you got on the phone
call here with me I haven't done the
math you can do the math that quick
that's pretty impressive good luck on
the recruiting trail and we appreciate
you joining us and congrats on the job
all right deeply appreciate you having
me hey that's uh Tom Tom Herman he's
hooking them already the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience